ليست المره الاولى لكنها الثانيه التي يتم
فيها اسقاط مسيره صينيه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
تقول شبكه سي ان ان التي زارت موقع حطام
مسيره من طراز موجن 5 برو شرقيه اوكرانيا
ان الطائره تم تحديثها وتسليحها لكنها
اسقطت بسلاح يدوي خفيف يفسر احد الجنود
الاوكران كيف جرت العمليه بين الحادي عشر
والثاني عشر من مارس حين وصلت معلومات
لجهاز الامن الاوكراني تفيد باطلاق مسيره
نحو هدف اوكراني فقامت اداره الامن
الاستراتيجي الى جانب وحدات عسكريه
متمركزه في الشرق باتخاذ حاله التاهب
بالقرب من مدينه سلوفيا نيسك وبالفعل رصدت
الطائره الصينيه ونظرا لارتفاع طيرانها
المنخفض جدا تمكن احد الجنود الاوكران من
اسقاط الطائره ببضع رصاصات فقط اطلقت من
سلاح كلاشنكوف سبب اخر يذكره ضابط متقاعد
بالجيش البريطاني للشبكه يفسر سهوله
استهداف المسيره الصينيه
لم تكن الطائره بدون طيار مجهزه بكاميرا
ما يجعلها اشبه بالقنبله الغبيه
ولا يرى الخبير البريطاني مبررا لتحديث
مسيره بدائيه وغير متطوره تكنولوجيا على
حد وصفه وتسليحها بمتفجرات تزن 20
كيلوغراما من الجيش الروسي فخلافا
للامكانيات العسكريه الاوكرانيه يمتلك
الروس اسلحه متطوره اكثر فعاليه قادره على
ضرب اهداف نوعيه بالاصل صممت
لاهداف تجاريه ولخدمه قطاعي الصناعه
والزراعه من قبل شركه تقع في مدينه شمال
الصينيه الساحليه تباع الواحده منها بنحو
15000 دولار امريكي على عده مواقع
الكترونيه ونظرا لسهوله اقتنائها ورواجها
تعرف بدرون علي بابا
بالرغم من ادانه الشركه الصينيه لاستخدام
منتجاتها عسكريا من قبل طرفي النزاع في
اوكرانيا غير ان المساله اثارت جدلا خصوصا
ان كندا وتايوان تساهمان في تزويد اجزاء
مهمه من الطائره مكرم حناوي العربيه